-We're hanging out
with Jeremy Renner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
His new show "Hawkeye" debuts on
Disney Plus this Wednesday.
-Yes.
-I got to see a snippet of it,
because it's Marvel
and they are very -- they don't
really let people see much.
-Right.
-In my snippet, was another
smaller snippet
of "a Captain America" musical.
-Uh-huh.
-Could there be an actual
"Avengers" musical
in the works on Broadway?
Well, I...
[ Laughter ]
Well, I'm not sure about that.
Look, it was actually the last
scene that we shot in the show.
Actually, you got to see it.
It's quite a show.
-It's really good.
-It's actually pretty
danged good.
Kevin's mind is really
turning on this.
He's the head of Marvel.
-Yeah.
-And I have no idea what he's
going to do with it.
There's a lot more of the show
that's in the "Hawkeye" show,
but who knows, I don't know.
I'm not a soothsayer.
-No, but what I saw
was pretty good.
Did you do -- do you know if
there's more than one song?
-I think there are.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. I don't want to get you
in trouble, but alright.
I like that answer.
[ Laughter ]
Can I ask you about some rumors?
-Sure, what do you got?
Okay.
-I got some answers for you.
-Okay, Yelena --
Florence Pugh
from "Black Widow."
-Who?
[ Laughter ]
Who's that?
-Yelena.
-Yeah, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't?
-I'm not sure.
-Yeah?
-It doesn't sound familiar.
-Yeah, she knows you.
-Is that right?
-I'm just wondering if she --
-Are you talking about thing at
the end of "Black Widow."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
I watched that with my niece,
and she's like,
"Oh, Uncle Jeremy,
what did you do?"
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I said, "I didn't do
anything darling."
-Oh, okay.
-And that's all I know
about that.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
[ Laughs ]
How about this?
After this show...
-Yeah?
-...will we see you play
Hawkeye again?
-Who?
[ Laughter ]
-Yelena.
-Sounds familiar.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, okay. Perfect.
I don't want to --
What can we tell everyone
"Hawkeye" is about?
-Hawkeye, well, what I love
about it, first of all,
we got to kind of introduce
the world
to Clint Barton in a bigger way
because there's six hours.
We can spend a lot more time
on just the characters
and the new characters
introduced.
But it's also in a world
of this world, right?
It's not in a galactic with the
aliens and all these things.
It's in a really practical world
like a superhero
with no superpowers.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jeremy Renner
in "Hawkeye."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Come on.
-Ah.
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Whoa, whoa!
Put him at!
[ Whooshes ]
What are you doing?
-Put him out! Here's on fire!
-Told you.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Got to get that suit.
Come on!
That's all you've got?!
Throw another one!
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jeremy Renner, everybody!
"Hawkeye" premieres Wednesday
on Disney Plus.